ARE A AB TWO THIRTY SEVEN OR
EXPAND ACCESS TO SAY CONSUMER
LOANS BY RAISING THE UPPER LIMIT
OF LOANS AVAILABLE UNDER THE
PILOT PROGRAM TO SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
SOME OF THE MANY PROTECTIONS
INCLUDED IN THE PILOT PROGRAMS
THAT DO NOT EXIST IN THE CFL
INCLUDE INTEREST RATES CAPTIVE
36%.
LOANS MUST BE UNSECURED LENDERS
MUST COMPLETE UNDERWRITING TO
ENSURE BORROWERS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REPAY.
LENDERS MUST REPORT LOANS TO
CREDIT AGENCIES AND A PREMIUM
PAYMENT PENALTIES.
IT'S BEEN A THE UPPER LIMIT OF
THE PILOT PROGRAM TO SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED WOULD PROVIDE
RELIEF TO CONSUMERS BY MAKING
LOANS.
OVER TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
AVAILABLE UNDER THE CURRENT
PILOT PROGRAM AB TWO THIRTY
SEVEN INCLUDES A COST RECOVERY
MEASURE THAT ALLOWS THE DB O. TO
CHARGE LICENSEES AN ADDITIONAL
FEE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
RECOVERING THE COSTS OF
CONDUCTING FINDER EXAMINATIONS.
WHEN WE GET ENOUGH PEOPLE HERE I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
LOOKING AROUND THE ROOM FISHING
SPENDING TIME.
STRETCHING.
MOVING FORWARD MEMBERS DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THAT MAY BE
OF ASSISTANCE IN.
MISTER CALDERON YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
NO.
WE NEED ONE MORE MEMBER TO MAKE
A QUORUM THIS DOES ENJOY A
SUPPORT SUPPORT SO WHEN WE GET
HERE WITH THIS COULD MOVE FAST.
ONE MORE MEMBER.
BY THE WAY WE HAVE TO DO TAKE
ROLE PRIOR TO THE VOTE.
YOU YOU DON'T HAVE TO STAY THERE
YOU THINK MINE UP.
FOR YOU CAN STAIRS ALL DOWN
MAYBE WE'LL CHANGE OUR MINDS
[inaudible]
NOT.
WELL WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
SATELLITE WOULD YOU PLEASE.
NOW CLICK WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
BIGELOW PRESIDENT BLOOM
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BROUGH [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CHAO.
FONG.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
QUIRK HERE BREATH.
MOVE THE BELL.
RECORD LOWS --
SOMEBODY [inaudible]
WHEN?
MISS KOREA THANK YOU.
CALL THE ROLL. OH NEVER MIND
TWICE.
THIS WEEK I DON'T HAVE.
LET ME TRY TO SHE ALL WEEK.
THIS HAD TO DO PASSED WITHIN A
ROLL CALL [inaudible]
WHERE?
YOU WANT TO WAIT FOR ANY UPS AND
WELL IT TURNED [inaudible]
TWICE LITTLE.
IF IT'S UNREAL.
ADAM WAS GONNA A CHAIR FOR A
COUPLE OF TIMES.
AND I GOT [inaudible]
OVER HERE [inaudible]
IT'S DIFFERENT.
DID YOU TAKE OTHER FOLDERS
[inaudible]